le secrétaire général de la cgt
française est en martinique à l'occasion
des 80 ans de la cgt martiniquaise
philippe martinez bonjour bonjour merci
d'être avec nous hier soir à la
mutualité vous avérée expliqué les
enjeux du syndicalisme d'aujourd'hui
contester la même crise du gouvernement
du capitalisme
être force de proposition philippe
martinez ne faudrait-il pas imaginer une
autre façon de mener ce combat syndical
on rappelle qu'en france moins de 10 %
des travailleurs sont syndiqués
je pense que le taux de syndicalisation
n'a pas grand chose à voir avec notre
façon de faire du syndicalisme le faible
taux de syndicalisation en france est
due essentiellement à la peur il faut
rappeler que beaucoup de syndicalistes
sont réprimés licenciés et avec des
célèbres affaires même menacé de prison
je pensais au goodyear et où air france
d'ailleurs c'est les sondages disque 80
% des salariés ont peur de syndiqués
c'est pour ça qu'il ne se syndiquent pas
par contre oui effectivement nous
pratiquons un syndicalisme qui consiste
à contester a proposé contestée parce
qu'on ne veut pas se fondre dans le
moule des idées dominantes et en même
temps proposer des alternatives sociales
vont refuser de rentrer dans les rangs
comme le souhaite le medef le
gouvernement à ces fameuses personne du
cac 40
mais il rêve le medef le gouvernement
vers un certain nombre de politiques de
droite comme de gauche d'un syndicalisme
qui accompagnent les restructurations
c'est à dire on nous annoncerait des
licenciements il faudrait dire ok
d'accord on va essayer que ça soit le
moins grave possible c'est pas possible
on sait ce que ça veut dire le chômage
pour des familles démunies des millions
de familles donc nous refusons ce type
de syndicalisme c'est à dire accompagner
des restructurations des mauvaises lois
etc
l'ennemi très clairement identifiés pour
vous c'est le système capitaliste
l'ennemi c'est ce qui profite du travail
des autres pour s'enrichir faut rappeler
que les 40 plus grandes entreprises de
la bourse de paris font des profits
énormes
la france est le troisième pays au monde
en termes de dividendes versés aux
actionnaires c'est plusieurs milliards
et et d'un autre côté on dit
au peuple aux citoyens il ya peu
d'argent il faut faire des économies
c'est que le travail coûte trop cher en
france oui oui c'est un gros mot le coût
du travail pour nous c'est un gros mot
vous savez quand des pdg de très grandes
entreprises qui gagnent jusqu'à 15
millions d'euros par an je pense à celui
de renault
mon patron dit à ses salariés vous êtes
trop payés alors que la moyenne des
salaires dans des entreprises tournent
entre 1500 et 1600 euros qu'il n'y a pas
d'augmentation de salaire c'est
particulièrement indécent c'est le
capital c'est c'est ce qu'on appelle oui
le capital c'est à dire ceux qui
spéculent avec le travail des autres qui
engrange les profits engrangés les
l'argent et puis d'un autre côté des
salariés la majorité qui sont soit au
chômage soit précaire vous êtes ok
surtout une stratégie de la part de
celles à trois comme vous dites
philippe martin et l on cherche à
culpabiliser le travailleur oui oui
c'est exactement ça c'est toujours de la
faute des travailleurs il ne s'en rend
pas compte
il n'a pas envie de se syndiquer
justement pour contrebalancer tout cela
je pense que tous les salariés on l'a vu
dans le dans le mouvement qui nous a
beaucoup occupé tout le printemps les
salariés ont envie de s'engager envie de
de prendre leurs affaires en main mais
c'est difficile c'est souvent en période
de crise que les mobilisations sont les
plus compliqués parce que vous vous le
savez très bien ici en martinique la
peur du chômage s'apaisent sur
l'implication des gens dans la vie
citoyenne et est le syndicalisme c'est
l'engagement citoyen car c'est trop tard
c'est un combat perdu d'avancé
alors non moi je suis résolument
optimiste il ya besoin de d'expliquer
d'aller voir les salariés de passer du
temps avec eux pour ceux qui travaillent
pour les le fait ça depuis des années
philippe martin et je pense qu'on le
fait pas assez
je pense qu'on ne fait pas assez et vous
voyez les chiffres continué à descendre
comme ça en terme de nombre de
travailleurs syndiqués ça fait une pause
je me permets de vous corriger ça fait
dix ans que le chiffre est stable
il n'est pas assez il n'y a pas assez de
syndiqués mais le chiffre est stable
mais il ya besoin de passer beaucoup
beaucoup de temps avec les salariés nous
ne faisons pas assez
il faut aller sur leur lieu de travail
c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire mais il
faut le faire beaucoup plus les salariés
ce sont les vrais experts du travail ils
savent où il faut investir ils savent
combien d'emplois faut créer je pense
par exemple dans les hôpitaux il ya une
forte pression sur les salariés nous
explique quand on va les voir en bas là
il manque deux personnes sauf
qu'évidemment il faut se mobiliser pour
dire à ceux qui nous dirigent
oui oui c'est pas la peine de te trouver
des projets de lois qui vont à
l'encontre des salariés
voilà des choses très concrètes et hier
soir vous avez développé cette notion du
du syndicalisme indépendant s'expliquer
sans audit heures de la première
le syndicat indépendant c'est quoi selon
vous celui qui vient qui vient
concurrencer la cgt par exemple le
syndicaliste a indiqué le syndicaliste
aède défendant alléger la loi travail
c'est une des caractéristiques de leur
travail c'est que il belloy travail va
donner la possibilité à des patrons sur
tous les gros de désigner des salariés
lambda en général ce sont d un ou deux
salariés proches de la direction pour
créer un syndicat et je disais hier soir
que en général ce syndicat s'appelle
toujours syndicats indépendants
ça donne une bonne figure mais il n'est
jamais indépendant de la direction et ça
permet de la chine toujours ce que
propose le patron comme il est très
indépendant il signe toujours ce que
propose le patron alors quelque chose
que vous avez donc il hier soir avec ses
syndiqués cgt martinique qui sont venus
vous voir cette notion qui consiste à
dire que le travailleur ne dois jamais
revenir en arrière dans son parcours dès
sa première fiche de paie on ne peut pas
revenir en arrière selon vous dans ce
dans ces acquis par exemple c'est une
proposition de la cgt une proposition
vraiment moderne
ça s'appelle la sécurité sociale
professionnelle comme ça pourrait
intégrer d'ailleurs la sécurité sociale
comme la maladie ou la famille c'est à
dire qu'une fois qu'on a un pied dans la
vie active
eh bien on ne peut plus revenir en
arrière en termes de qualification de
droit au congé de droit à la formation
de votre salaire donné évidemment niveau
de salaire à vous trouver des solutions
faut trouver des financements mais je
vous ai dit qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'argent dans les poches de certains
là c'est pas gagné ce combat là mais il
faut il faut proposer des choses
modernes
est ce que travailler 44 heures par
semaine est ce que changer d'entreprise
toutes les semaines c'est se projeter
vers l'avenir c'est être moderne où
c'est un retour vers le passé
c'est le travail à la tâche c'était ce
qui se passait au 19e siècle position
moderne pour position modem vous dites
lorsqu'on lorsqu'on écoute par exemple
les candidats à la primaire de la droite
et du centre
ils disent que la cgt bon ça fait partie
peu de la préhistoire oui oui c'est sûr
que on n'a pas la même
on n'a pas les même avis que ceux qui
sont à la primaire la droite me propose
de travailler très très longtemps eux
proposent de dpi est de faire travailler
ceux qui n'ont pas de boulot pour un
revenu de 400 ou 500 euros qui est
moderne
je le répète qui est moderne ce n'est
pas une proposition à 5 euros de l'heure
bien sûr qui est moderne ceux qui
veulent revenir au 19e siècle où ceux
qui se projette vers le 22ème siècle
voilà c'est ce sont des vrais débats et
quand on voit tant de richesses dans le
monde et qu'on voit tant de misère on se
dit faut un autre partage de ces
richesses pour que la majorité profite
de ce que la mairie la minorité vol il
faut continuer à résister dit vous par
exemple face à cette loi travail le
texte est passé mais la résistance
pourrait encore s'organiser selon vous
au sein de chaque entreprise là où les
discussions commencent le texte est pas
et a été promulguée il n'est pas passé
il est passé nul bahreïn c'est la
démocratie à la sauce gouvernement valls
oui il ya besoin que dans les
entreprises que ça devient concret quand
on vous dit à vos heures supplémentaires
était majoré de 25 %
elles seront maintenant majorée de 10%
c'est très concret pour les salariés et
donc il va il faut se mobiliser
notre slogan c'est pas de la pas de
l'oie travail dans nos boîtes et il ya
déjà des mobilisations importantes dans
diverses entreprises les gens courent à
cette résistance peut encore organiser à
ce niveau là c'est comme d'habitude ce
qu'on dit résistance et propositions
alternatives
il faut travailler vers un monde
meilleur c'est ce qu'on essaye de faire
la cgt et dans le même temps il y à ces
recours des nations unies de
l'organisation internationale du travail
à l'encontre de cette loi travail
promulguées en france mais on y croyait
c'est en tout cas c'est inquiétant que
des grandes organisations comme l'oit l
organisation internationale du travail
et l'onu
pointe du doigt une loi française avec
une ministre qui leur répond mais vous
n'avez rien compris à la loi relisez la
alors qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
vous en tant que cgt eh bien nous allons
avec d'autres organisations syndicales
travailler pour que juridiquement tant
au niveau national qu'au niveau
international on puisse limiter voire
supprimer des articles de cette loi qui
sont soit anticonstitutionnelle soit
vont à l'encontre des intérêts de sa vie
c'est encore possible de parler
intersyndicale bien sûr bien sûr il faut
jamais ce même si force ouvrière se peut
retirer de ce à dire qu'on sache jamais
se résoudre à la division syndicale
quand les syndicalistes ne se sert plus
la main
ce sont les patrons qui se frotte les
leurs philippe martinez et en martinique
à l'occasion des 80 ans de la cgtm
martinique c'était le 27 octobre 1936
comment jugez vous cette petite soeur
martiniquaise
c'est pas une petite soeur ce sont des
amis des frères c'est une ax est une
organisation indépendante de la cgt mais
à qui nous travaillons beaucoup
nous avons les mêmes repères les mêmes
références et il faut je suis là avec
d'autres de mes camarades pour continuer
et amplifier cette coopération entre nos
deux organes nos deux grandes
organisations 600h arnaudas secrétaire
générale de la cgtm a eu raison de
remettre le seul maire à sa place lors
de l'émission politique
elle a été parfaite elle a été parfaite
c'était la vraie vie ghislaine contre
l'avis de ceux qui font la vie dans leur
salon loin des préoccupations des
salariés elle a été parfaite
elle lui a remis les pieds dans la
réalité de ceux qui souffrent et de ceux
qui travaillent et je peux vous dire
bonne journée philippe bonne journée
merci secrétaire général de la cgt
philippe martin et c'est avec nous dans
ce sens qu'a dit merci